now okay i i couldn't i couldn't think
of a picture for this
so um i will forgive you if you have no
idea what this refers to but hopefully i
can justify it
this is about persistence
persistence uh no wait sorry no that's
wrong push this into another one
this is diligence this is this is what i
asked you for and yeah anyway
okay diligence perfect example of we're
an expert in an exosystem anyway
so diligence what i mean by that is uh
when we say someone is a diligent person
what do we mean
what kind of quality is that never give
up uh ah now that's persistence when
they never give up or perseverance
diligence i think is about attention
to detail hence the magnifying glass
right attention to detail
so here's what a good expert will do
this right they'll know the important
details in a situation
right and in trying to make a choice
they'll zoom in on those details and if
it's a good expert
they'll always get all the important
ones all the time until they'll make a
good decision
okay but two things sometimes
an expert will forget little details
because they're human humans make errors
right another way of thinking about that
thinking about to the clinical decision
support system right
one of the most important jobs of
doctors is to diagnose
okay just to try and work out what's
going on here now diligence comes into
play for a doctor
because there's a series of questions
that they're going to want to ask to try
and determine okay what are your
symptoms
what's a likely kind of diagnosis what's
sort of predictable for your condition
that kind of thing
now as humans right even after years and
years of training
suppose you've got a series of like
maybe 10 to 15 questions you ask someone
and on that basis you make a diagnosis
well what if you forget a couple
right and without that information you
make an incorrect
or a um not not broad enough diagnosis
okay
just because you are diligent enough
right and that's sort of a human problem
now
expert systems by contrast they're
always going to look at every single
detail
even the you know the trivia ones and
they're always going to ask every single
question
even the trivial ones okay so diligence
attention to detail
right never gonna miss a little you know
thing is a really helpful thing that you
get from computer-based systems
all right let's get going okay now this
is the one i think i wanted to um
call persistence persistence
now i don't mean persistence as in
perseverance
uh i mean persistence as in something is
always there
like 7-eleven right so one of the great
things
about an expert system that an expert
doesn't have is that you can access them
all the time i suppose you could call
this accessibility
okay now this is like computer based
systems do this all the time right
for instance if um unless you live close
to like a you know 24 hour kmart which
is weird i nev i don't understand 24
hour k months but anyway
in the middle of the night i need to go
buy some track pants you know
um unless you need one of those you
generally can't go and buy anything you
want anytime during the day
because people have to go to sleep and
have weekends and stuff like that right
but amazon never sleeps amazon is like a
7-eleven up in the sky and you get
anything
right so persistence it's always there
the expert system is always there never
needs to take a break
okay never needs to have a nap never
needs to go on holidays never used to
eat
apart from you know like electricity and
stuff which we can supply
you know all the time uh it's always
accessible
24 hours a day seven days a week okay
okay now this next one
okay have a have a look at this picture
uh what is it this is it this this guy
here the standing guy is a chess master
and what's he doing
uh if you could see closely he's walking
around a sort of
a square of tables and it looks to me
like there's at least
you know seven or eight games going on
at once
and it's probably more outside the frame
that we can't see and uh if you ever
seen this before it's quite thrilling to
watch
um he's just walking from board to board
and he's making a move
and he goes to the next board and he
looks at it and then he makes a move and
in all likelihood depending on how good
a master he is he'll probably win all of
those games maybe one or two
he might lose okay now what's this about
this is about availability right
namely this chess master as good as he
is
is only available to play one game at a
time
he maintains the illusion of playing
multiple games
at the same time but really you know if
you freeze him in time he's he's only
dealing with
one game and he's just doing them in
sequence okay
however an expert system right how is it
different
how is the expertise and knowledge of
the expert system
available in a different way that is the
chess master
well in a in a true way simultaneous
uh users sorry multiple users
can access the expert system
simultaneously
and get responses from it
immediately right there's no kind of
wait hold on
um the teacher's busy right now with
someone else you can't ask them
questions because they they're you know
uh fully engaged and you can't actually
interrupt into the conversation and get
meaningful help out of them
extra systems not true okay
all right one last advantage okay
yeah this guy just found him um i
i don't i don't remember his name so i'm
going to get it for you
this this man is general man
kimura how's that my year my year 10
no year 8 japanese success okay now
mr kimura is uh the oldest man in the
world
uh at the moment or the yeah oldest man
probably the oldest woman who might be a
bit older because i think we've been
generally a bit more
they last a bit longer so it says he's a
former postman
good on him he's 115 years and well at
the time of writing this he was 258 days
old
which was in january uh
january so if if he's still alive he
might be 116.
yeah anyway okay yeah happy guy so
oldest man in the world now i think like
the whatever the guinness world record
must be 121
122 something like that okay so
you've got a fixed age limit really
on all of the experts in the world okay
and to be honest most people don't
really get past that it's sort of like
woohoo if i get past 100 like let alone
150 160.
okay so therefore what's the advantage
of the expert system over a human expert
right
okay now now we feel this really keenly
because
you know not just is it that you know
experts will
eventually pass away because they're
human beings but also
um they will not just pass away they'll
leave organizations so we're losing
you know over the last few years and in
the next few years to come our school is
losing
heaps of expert teachers a lot in my
department i mean they're all over the
place right
but this is just what happens people
retire they were only going to teach for
like
45 years max okay and that's not that
long when you think about
um how many how many teach how many
students need all the expertise of these
people right
so an excellent assistant right if you
could condense all of the knowledge and
wisdom and experience
of a human being into a computer system
you'd be able to access it forever that
would be great wouldn't it
okay